Tu as fait la plus grosse erreur de ta vie, étranger.
Dommage que tes derniers mots soient une connerie, cowboy.
On attend quoi là?
Que l’horloge sonne.
Oui enfin, il est moins le quart,
on va peut-être pas attendre un quart d’heure sous la flotte.
Oui c’est pas faux.
-Ben oui.
Ce que je te propose, c’est que je vais compter jusqu’à trois,
et à trois tu pourras dire adieu à la vie mon gars.
Un …
Deux …
Attends, attends, attends,
c’est à trois on tire
ou c’est « trois » et après on tire ?
Normalement c’est trois et après on tire,
je compte jusqu’à trois et là on a dégainé à peu près,
et à ce moment-là on se tire dessus.
Non, non c’est pas clair ton truc là…
Non, non, ce que je te propose:
je vais faire «trois, deux, un...
go!»
Et tu voudrais qu’on se tire dessus à «go»?
N’importe quoi non, franchement, tu mériterais que je te tire dessus direct.
Non, non, c’est bon
ça va, je vais pas le faire.
Alors,
on va faire comme dans les courses:
je tire un coup en l’air,
et après on se tire dessus.
Non c’est une connerie.
En fait c’est une connerie parce que si je tire en l’air je ne pourrais pas...
… Rah mais ça va, je propose.
Attends, j’ai une idée.
Eh toi là!
Moi?
C’est toi qui va tirer en l’air.
J’ai pas d’arme moi en fait.
Tiens.
J’ai plus d’arme.
Bon, attends.
Je jette la pièce en l’air,
quand elle touche le sol, on se tire dessus.
C’est bien ça.
Du coup on fait quoi?
Il te reste de la monnaie?
J’ai un billet.
Non, mais non, ça clairement c’est …
Désolé!
Non c’est parce qu’on faisait aussi un duel …
Et nous on s’était calé sur horloge du coup
Ok à trois on lève.
Attends, attends
à trois on lève
ou trois et après on lève?
On lève.